اشكر كل من حضر والمنظمات الدوليه سيد
الامين العام
السيدات والساده الكرام مع حفظ الالقاب
الشيخ هناك ايضا الكثير من البرلمانيين
والرسائل الشركات عزيزه سيد الرئيس رئيس
المؤتمر الاصدقاء الاعزاء انا سعيد جدا ان
التقي بكم مجددا اليوم في هذا المكان
حيث منذ 60 عاما يتم اجراء
مناقشات من شانها ان تهيكل عالمنا وتقوم
بتعض افكارنا على ضفتي الاطلسي ونرى كما
راينا وكما ذكر الرئيسكي والمستشار احيي
مداخلتهما
بعد عده ايام
سيمر عام تماما على الحرب الكارثيه التي
شنتها روسيا على اوكرانيا
لم ياتي وقت النتائج ولكن هناك حصيله
نستطيع القيام بها اريد ان اركز مداخلتي
بشان هذه الحرب التي سنتها روسيا على
اوكرانيا ولكن هناك لن نقول ولن ننسى
الحروب الاخرى في القوقاز وفي شرق الاوسط
وفي افريقيا ومكافحه الارهاب والمسائل
المتعلقه بالامن النوويه والمشاكل
المطروحه في مناطق اخرى
ولكن بشكل اساسي سنتحدث عن اوكرانيا بعد
سنه من هذه الحرب
الحصيله
لنزاع كارثي غير مبرر اريد هنا ان اركز
على نقطه واحده ان هذه الحرب هي ليست فقط
حرب للاوروبيين واوروبا انها تمس الكوكبه
بر لان هذا الاعتداء
مغير المبرر وانا اصف هذه الحرب كما ذكرت
في الجميع العامل المتحده بانها نوع من
الاستعمار الجديد
والامبراليه الجديده هي تستنكر هويه الجار
والاستيلاء على اراضيه دون اي احترام
وايضا
الاحتفاظ بحق الوصايه على شعب اخر ان قبول
ذلك وغمض الاعين
وهذا يعني بان هذه الكولونياليه الجديده
والامبرياليه الجديده يمكن ان تكون في
جميع انحاء العالم من ناحيه اخرى هذه
الرؤيه
اطاحت بكل
القيم العالميه وهذا الامر تم التاكيد
عليهم من قبل قوه اهداف
مقعد دائم في مجلس امن الدولي
وبالتالي هذا افضل الى
انتشاري جرائم حرب بصوره منهجيه واريد هنا
ان نحيي العمل في مجال الامني
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هناك وفي
ايران ايضا بطبعه الحال مثلا المدير العام
الروسي كانت هناك نتائج كارثيه وفي الواقع
ان روسيا هي التي تتحمل مسيرتها الكامله
هناك الازمه الغذائيه
وكل الرهانات والمضاربات على المنتجات
الغذائيه نحن نتخذ التدابير بشانه اكثر
بلدان هشاشه من بعض البلدان في العالم من
يقول بان هذه قضيه اوروبيه
وهناك تشاطر في الذنب ولكن اريد هنا ان
اؤكد بان هناك معتدي ومعتدى عليه وهناك
مبادئ واضحه وبانه لا ينبغي ان نتركها
نترك روسيا تنتصر اذا اردنا ان نحتفظ بس
دائما في العالم
النقطه الثانيه او الملاحظه الثانيه التي
اود الاشاره اليها
هي
بالقول بان هذا الاعتداء الروسي افضل الى
اربعه
نقاط للفشل نقطه الفشل الاولى الفشل الاول
فيما يتعلق ميدانيا كان يعتقد بان هذا
الانتصار سيكون سريعا في عده اسابيع او
عده اشهر ان الشجاعه الرائعه
للجيش والشعب الاوكراني
وللقاده ولكل القوى السياسيه الذين احييهم
هنا والاصدقاء الحاضرين هنا والرئيس الذي
تحدث قبل قليل عبر الشاشه
نتائج صعبه ان هذه المقاومه في كييف
واستعاده الاراضي في الشمال بالاضافه الى
كل ما تم نجاحه في خرسون
الى فشل الخطه الروسيه الاوليه الفشل
الثاني المتعلق بالعقليه الاستعماريه
الكولونياليه كان هناك خطاب
يسعى الى وضع مناطق للنفوذ والردع وكان
يتم الشرح حتى من اجل تبرير واطفاء
المشروعيه على هذا النزاع هذا الامر لم
يحدث ولم ينجح بعد سنه من واجبنا نحن ان
نستمر في هذا العمل المتمثل بالشرح
والتوضيح بان روسيا اليوم هي روسيا تقوم
بقوه
لعدم التوازن والزعزع ليس في اوكرانيا
ولكن في شكل الاوسط وفي افريقيا عبر
مجموعه ايفاغنر
قبل سنه كنت في روسيا عملت واحد تحدثت مع
السلام بوتين قال لي بكل ثقه انا وثقت به
قال لي بان مجموعه فاغنر غير مرتبطه بنا
والذين مشاكل معها هنا في روسيا ولكن
اليوم هم يقولون بان مجموعه فاجنر لها دور
رئيسي هيا تطلعوا بدور
دبلوماسيا عسكريا ومفويا جديد في العالم
وهذا يفضي الى انتشار الجريمه
وعدم الاستقرار في كل انحاء العالم الفشل
الثاني لروسيا هو الفشلها في قراءه
المستقبل ان النتيجه الواضحه افضت الى
تعزيز اوكرانيا وقواتها
واختيار فنلندا والسويد بالانضمام الى
الحلف الاطلسي وهنا اريد الى قادات هذين
البلدين باننا نقف الى جانبهم في هذا
الطلب
وايضا هناك زياده دعم الدوليه وهناك شك
كبير بشان روسيا وهناك ايضا
شك كبير كيف يمكن ان نعتقد بان التحديات
في منطقه القوقاز سيتم
حلها
عبر هذه الكنيه الجديده الروسيه اقولها
امام عزيزي بشنيان من ارمينيا وهناك الفشل
الرابع
هو الفشل الذي
يتعلق بالسلطه الروسيه في العالم
منتج للمنتجات بلد اقتصاد للابتكار
واجمالي ناتج محلي ضعيف
وهناك ايضا شك كبير من قبل كل الجيران
بروسيا نعم وفي خضم بكل ذلك استطيع ان
اكرر واعيد حيث انني كنت ادافع من هذه
المنصه من هذا المنبر لن يغير احدنا
جغرافيه روسيا روسيا ستكون دائما على
الارض الاوروبيه ولا يمكن لاحدنا ان يتحدث
عن ويتنبا بهذا
المستقبل لا يمكن ان يكونك السلام دائم
دون ان نتناول هذه المساله الروسيه
بصيره ودون اي تهاون وفي اطار هذه الروح
سنعمل ونتقدم دون ايه تهاون او تبسيط وهذا
كان محل عملي ونشاطي في هذا المجال
دون اي تبسيط او سذاجه هناك تصميم
تاكيد على واجبنا والشجاعه من اجل الدخول
في المفاوضه من اجل التقدم ولكن اليوم
وبكل وضاحه الوقت ليس وقت المفاوضات الى
ان روسيا اختارت الحرب واختارت ان تكثف
الحرب
واختارت ان تعمل حتى ارتكابي جرائم الحرب
والاعتداء على المدنيين ان الحلول قصيره
الاجل هي بسيطه
ان لا يمكن لروسيا ان تنتصر في هذه الحرب
وهذا الاعتداء الروسي يجب ان يفشل لا
يمكننا ان نقبل تبسيط اللجوء الى القوه
واذا تركنا ذلك فان الامن الاوروبي
والاستقرار العالمي سيكون محطه شك
وهذا ما نقوم به مع شركاء الاوروبيين
والامريكيين واخرين منذ البدايه
من اجل التاكيد على دور الامني ودعم
عقوبات عشره حزم من العقوبات اتخذها
الاوروبيون ضد روسيا منذ البدايه وايضا
دعم عسكري
وانساني ومديء لاوكرانيا وشعبها من خلال
تنظيم مؤتمرات للبنى التحتيه المدنيه
تجهيزات تم نقلها وايضا تعبئه كل جهود
الحلف الاطلسي اشكر لمن العام
للحلفان فرنسا اكدت دائما على الجوانب ذات
الاولويه المدفعيه والدفاع الجوي مع
التدريب ايضا للجنود للالاف من الجنود
الاوكرانيين ونحن ايضا نؤكد على التعزيز
رومانيا واستونيا وفي الاجواء في
الاوروبيه ولا يسمى في الجناح الشرقي من
الحلف الاساسي تعزيز وجوهنا في البحر
المتوسط حيث هناك قوات
فرنسيه جويه بحريه تعمل هناك
نحن قمنا بترجمته هذه الامور ميدانيا
اعتبارا من شهر فبراير عام 2022 نحن
سنستمر في ذلك وسنعزز ذلك في هذا الوقت
الذي اتوجه فيه اليكم علينا ان نعزز دعمنا
وجهودنا من اجل دعم المقاومه مقاومه الشعب
والجيش الاوكراني
ومواجهتي
وايضا
الرد من اجل التاكيد على المفاوضات حسب
الشروط الاوكرانيه وقاده
اوكرانيا
نحن جاهزون
لتعزيز لان الاسابيع والاشهر القادمه هي
حاسمه ونحن مستعدون
للنزاع
مطول لا اقول ذلك متمنيا ذلك ولكن علينا
ان نكون ذي مصداق في قدراتنا الدائمه في
تقديم الجهود وفرنسا تندرج في هذا المجال
اؤكدوا على الاراده والتصميم ان نقف الى
جانب اوكرانيا هذه الطريقه الوحيده من اجل
اعاده الاطراف الى طاوله المفاوضات بطريقه
مقبوله اعاده روسيا الى ثوره المفاوضات من
اجل التفاوض بشان سلام دائم في اللحظه
التي يختارها الاوكرانيون اقول هذا
واطلق بعض
النداءات الى الاصدقاء الاوروبيين
واريد ان تشاطر هذه القناعات الندال الاول
في الاستثمار الكبير في دفاعنا اذا اردنا
نحن كاوروبيين السلام علينا ان نتحلى
بالوسائل المواد في اطار المراجعه
الاستراتيجيه التي قدمته في شهر نوفمبر
الماضي الحكومه قدمت الى الجمعيه الوطنيه
مشروعه برمجه عسكريه فيما يتعلق بالفتره
و23 مثل ب400 مليار وهذه زياده كبيره جدا
مقارنه بالبرمجه العسكريه السابقه اعاده
التسلح يعني ايضا هو ان نعزز القواعد
الدفاعيه والعسكريه ان نقوم بتعزيز كل
الاليات التي قمنا بتطويرها مؤخرا ولا
سيما في اطار اجنده ايفرسه التي اعتمدناها
قبل سنه العديد من الدول التي تريد ان
تسرح اوكرانيا هي مرتبطه بقرارات بلدان
غير هو شركات عسكريه غير اوروبيه اذا اردت
اذا اردت اوروبا ان تدافع عن اوروبا عليها
ان تتسلح وان تؤكد على امكانيه التشغيل
البيني للحلف الاطلسي وتزيد من قدرات
الانتاجيه على الاراضي الاوروبيه نحن نريد
ان نعتمد قبل فرض الصيف برنامجا اوروبيا
للدفاع
هو ان نؤكد على الاستفاده قدر الامكان من
الصندوق الاوروبي للدفاع بين الاوروبيين
علينا ان نرى كيف يمكننا ان نصنع بشكل
اكبر او بشكل اسرع اذا اعتبارا من فصل
الربيع اردنا ان نعز من ذلك نريد ان نذهب
الى ابعد من ذلك من اجل المزيد من توحيد
المواصفات والمقاييس في هذا المجال النداء
الثاني
[موسيقى]
ناخذ كل العبر داخل هذه المحافل الدوليه
واريد ان اعيد
[موسيقى]
اعيد اقتراحي فيما يتعلق
بالردع النووي الفرنسي والمفهوم والمفهوم
الاوروبيه لفرنسا فيما يتعلق بالمصالح
الحيويه النداء الثالث فيما يتعلق بتعزيز
الامن من اجل ضمان مكانه اوروبا في كل
محفل في هذا المجال ولا سيما مثال المتعلق
بالصواريخ
متوسطه المدى في اطار نزع التسلح لقد اكدت
على وضع غير واضح الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الماضي قررت الخروج من
اتفاقيه الروس لم كانوا يحتاجون هذه
الاتفاقيه وكل هذه الاتفاقيه تعني
بتعني في الواقع وتتناول اراضينا دون ان
نكون نحن اقاربين معنيين بهذه الاتفاقيه
الامر يتعلق هنا بالامن الاوروبي علينا ان
نفكر بهذا الامن علينا ان نقوم بالتفاوض
بهذا الامر ونقوم بالضمان هذا الامر مع
الحلفاء الاطلسين ولكن ايضا نحن كاربيين
هذه الاسلحه متوسط المدى
فرنسا لم تكن
طرفا في هذه الاتفاقيه ولكن بعد ذلك راينا
بانه لم يكن فجاه اي اتفاقيه تشمل هذه
الصواريخ وعلينا ان نعمل في هذا الاطار
هذا
رهان اساسي من الدفاع عن اوروبا من اجل
اعاده التفاوض بهذا الشان ويجب على اوروبا
ان يكون لها مكانتها في هذا التفاوض بهذه
بشان هذه
النقاط هذا الموضوع هو من ضمن موضوع اكبر
ذكره المستشارت فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الجوي
الاوروبيه
واعتقد بان المتسار الالماني طرح اقتراحا
مهما مع البريطانيين والالمان البريطانيين
والفرنسيين علينا ان ندعو الى مؤتمر جويً
لاوروبا من اكل التعامل معهم من خلال
الصناعات وكل
للصناعات ولكن ايضا هذا الموضوع من
الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
وربما اولى من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه من
خلال ضم البعد
الردعي في هذا المجال اذا
مساله التسلح الفكري والمادي سيسمح لان
تكون لاوروبا مكانتها في المسائل الامنيه
النداء الاخر يتعلق
بتفادي العنف في قناتنا في
العقود الماضيه نحن سنكون بحاجه الى
الشفافيه وامكانيه التوقع واحترام عدم
احترام عدم اختراق الحدود اعاده التاكيد
على الردع في اوروبا اعاده التوازن للقوى
في اوروبا اعاده ايجاد هيكله للتسليح من
شانه ان يسمح الى تقليص
القوى وايضا وضع اطار للنزاعات المطوله
والاسيا ممكن الاستلهام من بعض الهياكل
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا انه اتحاد
الاوروبيه في كل ذلك ونحن نعمل في اطار
الاتحاد الاوروبي علينا ان نفكر باوروبا
اوسع مقارنه
بما قمنا به واقتراحنا بشان المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه
من خلال ضم قوى اختارت الخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن ما زالت حاضره في البعد
الجيوسياسي الاوروبيه
نعم وهناك بلدان اخرى هي طرف
ايضا وهناك قوى اخرى تود انضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي واتمنى ان يتمكنوا من
ذلك ولكن هم بعيدون اليوم من ان
نرويج وفي منطقه البلقان وملدا اذا هذه
المجموعه السياسيه الاوروبيه هي اطار
جيوسياسي من شانها ان تؤدي الى الوقايه من
الصراعات والنزاعات في هذا الاطار اعيد
واكرر عن دعمنا للرئيسه المولدافيه صندوق
التي ستقوم
بتنظيم مؤتمر بهذا الشان
نحن بحاجه الى بناء فضاء جديد للتعاون
داخل الاراضي الاوروبيه ان حلف اساسيه
طلعوا بدور اساسي في هذا المجال وهذا بين
بان كل اولئك الذي كان يعتقدون بان الدفاع
اوروبي قوي هو تهديد الحلف هؤلاء فهموا
اليوم بان العكس صحيح هذا الامر يعزز من
الحلف الاطلسي يتم القيام بذلك
بعمل مع الحلفاء الامريكيين
والكنديين والاستراليين من اجل سيف نحو
هدف مشترك اخيرا اريد ان اؤكد وادعو الى
نداء خامس فيما يتعلق بهذا الصراع والى
خارج الى ما بعد الصراع علينا ان نستمر في
العمل
بشان صراعات اخرى تهددنا نحن نواجه
خطرا يتمثل بان نكون في مواجهه مشاكل
استراتيجيه في اوكرانيا ولكن وفي نفس
الوقت علينا ان نواجه النزاعات في فضاءات
اخرى علينا ان ننسى الجاب السيبراني
الفضاء
المجالات البحريه وايضا هشاشه الديمقراطيه
فيما يتعلق بالاخبار الكاذبه والزعزع هذه
المخاطر سيتم استخدامها هذه الفضاء سيتم
استخدامها ربما من قبل روسيا او من قبل
قوى اخرى استبداديه وبالتالي في هكذا سياق
من شانها ان تستخدمها لزعزعه استقرارنا
وبالتالي علينا ان نعزز استقرارنا
واستثماراتنا وقدراتنا من اجل التعاون في
هذه الفضاءات في هذه الفتره ونداء الاخير
الى كل الاوروبيين
بالله اما بعد الاوروبيين ولكن اقول ربما
نداء الى الاوروبيين والامريكيين على وجه
التحديد لننخرط ايضا من اجل التحضير
للسلام في الاجر القصير علينا ان نكون
اقوياء وان نكون مصممين خلف اوكرانيا
وطالما استلزم الامر ذلك ولكن من الان
فعلا علينا ان نحضر لشروط السلام هذه هي
مسؤوليتنا الامر لا يتعلق هنا بالتسويه
انها روح روح المسؤوليه ان نكون ذي
مصداقيه اليوم وان نكون كذلك في المستقبل
ولكن علينا ان نحضر الشروط لذلك وسنقوم
بذلك من اجل الانخراط واشتراك الاخرين في
اسيا وفي المحيط الهادئ وفي الشرق الاوسط
وفي امريكا اللاتينيه
ربما هذه النقاط ورغم ما ذكرته في البدايه
هؤلاء يقولون بان هناك معايير مزدوجه انتم
تفكرون وتنفخون كثيرا على اوكرانيا ولكن
لا تقومون بنفس الشيء بالنسبه لنا لا بنفس
الشيء بالنسبه لمكافحه الفقراء او هناك
حروب مستمره لا تقوم نفس الشيء علينا ان
نستمع الى هؤلاء ونفكر بكل هذه المناطق
الجغرافيه حتى نقنعهم من اجل ان ينضموا
الينا للضغط على روسيا والتحضير للسلام
هذه هي مسؤوليتنا
علينا ان نعمل على ذلك من خلال الابتعاد
عن
ازدواجيه المعايير حيث نحن نقوم بكل هذه
الاستثمارات انا ادعو الاوروبيين
والامريكيين واعضاء مجموعه السبع والعشرين
من اجل مركبات على شراكه شماليه جنوبيه من
اجل اعاده النظر في شروط التعاون
والتضامن الدولي في مجال الصحه
والتربيه ومكافحه مكافحه
انعدام الامن الغذائي من اجل اعطاء
مصداقيه جديده للبلدان الغنيه مع ضم
البلدان الناشيه والبلدان الناميه في هذه
الجهود في هذه اللحظه التي ندافع فيها عن
مبادئنا نقول لهم نحن نريد باننا نريد
سلاما عادلا
ومستداما
واخذينه بعين الاعتبار في نفس الوقت
التحديات المناخيه هذه المسؤوليه هي
مسؤوليه ضروريه وعلينا ان لا ننسى ذلك
ابدا ان الاستجابه والرد لهذه هذا النزاع
يمر عبر الصرامه
والقدرات العسكريه ولكن ايضا
يستلزم ايضا انخراطا في السلام وفي سياسه
للتضامن يتم تعزيزها لقد اطلت كثيرا
اريد في الخاتمه ان اشكركم وان اشكركم على
سماح لي بمشاطرتكم هذه القناعات
[تصفيق]